[Musique]
c'est un projet avec des enfants en
difficulté et toi tu dois les garder
jusqu'à ce que je trouve un remplaçant
ok je vais essayer de nos débats du fait
en sorte
bonjour d'habitude les gens comme y
répondent
on va voir comment il se sent il a de la
ressource
moi je vais vous apprendre des vrais
trucs qui vont nous servir dans la vraie
vie
brossez vous les dents les esclaves à
l'époque c'était en fonction de leur
banque ont décidé si rester en vie ou si
on les tuait surtout toi on sait jamais
ils vous ont déjà eu une fois ça peut se
reproduire
on est ici pour travailler quelque chose
d'essentiel la communication annoncé
comme août et ma soeur
tex quoi à choper les hopla j'ai pas le
temps fait moi d europe là tu sois là
je connais pas vraiment votre histoire
mais tant d'amis là je pense pas que ce
soit bonne et on lui a beaucoup pris à
ce gamin mais il a bon fond
[Musique]
moi je suis pas doué pour parler aux
gens ça s'apprend jimmy pourquoi tu vas
parler six mois par les enfants de
gaulle est mort
n'oublie pas qu'un enfant qui cause des
problèmes cette aventure allemand
frontières
vous avez envie qu'il reste jusqu'à la
fin juste si le remplacer
c'est marrant ils sont vifs il souffre
en même temps ils lâchent rien rappelle
quelqu'un
c'est une question de mentalité si tu
leur donnes siad mieux ils vaudront est
ce qu'il ya de mieux
ces moyens que je te le dit pas assez
mais que ça fait pour moi c'est pas
quelque chose que j'oublie